So now we're ready to get back to the problem of extracting a list
that contains all the links in a webpage.
This is the first step towards our crawler, which will crawl a set of webpages,
finding all of the links that can be found from a seed page.
We're going to start with a webpage.
We have the url of some seed page.
We use the get_page procedure to get a string which is the text of that page.
That's got lots of stuff in it that we don't care about,
but it also includes some hyperlinks,
and inside the hyperlinks are the url's to that page links too.
Our goal is to define a procedure--we'll call it getalllinks--
that takes as input, a string representing the text on a webpage,
and produces as output, a list containing all of the url's that are linked to by that page.